soit en docteur merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors expliquez
nous vous comment vous vivez dans votre
cabinet on vous a souvent eu ici sur ce
plateau à distance c'est maintenant
l'est flux passion pour pour des tests
pcr
c'est bien ça l'afflux de patients
symptomatiques l'afflux est évident on
est à un moment où moi même je me
retrouve à 150 % de mon à petite ou
moyenne
je me retrouve avec un secrétariat qui
est incapable de répondre au téléphone
dans 87% des cas ce qu'il n'est jamais
arrivé en 15 ans d'exercice et même pas
pendant confirmant donc lui on a
énormément de patients symptomatiques
qui nécessiterait d'avoir un test pcr et
c'est bien inquiétant quand on entend
les dés que vous avez car j'en appelle
qu'un test d'esprit terre a pour but de
permettre lise allemands n'ont pas de
vous même mais isolement des cas
contacts que vous avez eue et surtout
des contacts de local contact donc si on
continue cette politique de tester les
gens agissent est quand ils sont quelque
part ils auront leurs résultats j'y vis
et nous ne stopperons pas nous la contre
ont simplement il c'est un vrai problème
savoir quelle est la stratégie est ce
que c'est de diminuer ou est ce que
c'est juste la côte est alors comment
faudrait-il faire docteur le grand pour
que ça soit plus efficace pour la
contrer la première des choses c'est que
chaque français se doit aujourd'hui
alors que detroit - fall très
d'explosion si vous voulez de faire très
attention à diminuer son nombre de cas
qu pas tous ne pourront plus prendre
autant de quelques contacts en charge ce
n'est pas possible on arrive
un tracé tout simplement les contacts
des positif il faut être raisonnable
vous devez mettre qu'est vous devez
limiter vos contacts dans la mesure du
possible limiter des fêtes les mariages
et compagnie ça n'est pas réussie que
j'ai encore testé aujourd'hui toute une
femme s'était rendue à un mariage la
semaine dernière comme un peu plus
vraiment on vous demande d'être
raisonnable et si vous ne l'êtes pas le
prix à payer en sera confirmant qu'il
était impossible dans un but économique
donc vraiment c'est la responsabilité
chacun qui fera qu' on arrivera à
l'épidémie mais on a besoin de calme
sérénité pouvoir on entend bien ça
tapait la fête aux français une chose
est sûre concernant les tests les
autorités misent désormais sur les tests
anti génie qui seront déployés cette
semaine en ile-de-france donc plus
rapide il détecte en revanche
apparemment un petit peu moins
d'individus infectés que l'examen par
pcr ça vous semble est quand même un bon
début une bonne chose
en fait il faudrait expliquer aux
français quelque chose de très simple
c'est que nous on ne teste pas quelqu'un
pour dans le but de lui annoncer un
diagnostic on ne faisait pas pour les
pcr ne fera pas protestantes yj notre
objectif c'est de limiter les contacts
de contact et uniquement ça puisque pour
ce qui est des personnes que nous
testons c'est déjà perdu d avance
ils sont infectés et pour leurs contacts
il est déjà trop tard et c'est seulement
en accélérant le diagnostic que derniers
temps de limiter la propagation et les
français eux dans leur côté se doivent
absolument de s'isoler au moindre
symptôme et je vous rappelle que les
symptômes sont divers et variés nous
avons à la fois des céphalées à la fois
la perte l'anoci et la perte du 1er de
l'odorat et du goût mais nous avons
aussi des diarrhées simplement s'en
remet doucement tout ce signe là doivent
faire panser vos colis
entraînée en isolement mais un autre
tout ils vont n'attendez pas d'avoir
rendez vous chez votre médecin
m'attendais pas de le faire votre tête
n'attendez surtout pas d'avoir un tel
test pour vous isoler alors c'est un
petit peu compliqué parce que c'est vrai
qu'on va pas tarder à rentrer dans des
périodes plus froides et également
l'aide grippe qui va s'inviter au milieu
ça paraît compliqué tout de même de
s'isoler de s'auto isolé quand on a un
gros rhume parce que en ce moment il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont des rhumes
c'est pas nécessairement le coc vide
alors ça veut dire quoi qu'on dit à son
patron ben alors je vais pas venir
pendant huit jours parce que j'ai un
gros ims a fait le coc vie de on se
trompe de diète des discours
je vais très clair et très fin je
préfère mettre sept jours d'arrêt le
temps que vous venez de résultats du
test à quelqu'un que de m quatorze jours
38 40 choix parce que quelqu'un est allé
au travail la responsabilité chacun dans
le nombre de personnes qu'ils vont
infecter était essentielle et donc oui
je j'entends bien il va falloir mettre
quelques arrêts et quand les symptômes
ont disparu
effectivement un green un mérite un
virage ça disparaît entre wasquehal jour
on sera fixé mais il faut me laisser
mettre en arrêt de travail
les gens et il faut que les gens nous
aident à se mettre en arrêt de travail
parce que nous aimons pas le seul alors
on a aussi l'application stop covin on
en parle le beaucoup n'est pas
franchement plébiscité il le faudrait en
ce moment c'est qu'on en a parlé un
piper ensemble déjà l'appliquer sur
celui de multipliera nombre de compacts
et puis on voit bien que
définition d'un calcul tac est
essentiellement à faire par le médecin
parce que c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
qu'un simple prolongement de bluetooth
non je m'appelle réellement revenir à
quai de sainte et biologiques
le test peut être prescrit par un
médecin parce qu'il a une utilité
on entend des votre confrère qui est
actuellement confiné qui attend un
résultat peut-être en variété il y avait
même eu besoin de le tester il suffisait
de l'isoler au niveau vont garder de
toute façon ces contacts de contacts
sont déjà contaminés et ont déjà
contaminé tourne donc face inférieure
soit en test dans les deux premiers
jours trois premiers jours sont un test
plus et on l'a alors vous sortez un
livre en cette rentrée un journal d'un
médecin au temps du coronavirus vous
raconter votre expérience de généraliste
au plus fort de la crise sanitaire vous
expliquait d'ailleurs avoir voulu
alerter la presse régionale sans avoir
été pris vraiment au sérieux vous vous
le regrettez on a toujours un temps de
décalage et un temps breton
c'est vrai que vos confrères de la
presse régionale avait pris un peu de
retard et puis je le comprends quand on
tire la sonnette d'alarmé n'est pas
forcément tout le monde a entendu et en
même temps que je ne leur ai jamais fait
de remerciement pour vos confrères
spéciaux qui sont venus questionner et
vous retourner pour regarder les choses
différemment et je pense ils ont eu
totalement raison
merci beaucoup docteur le grand médecin
généraliste auteur d'un journal ou d'un
médecin au temps du courant navires us
aux éditions de l'archipel merci à vous